من ثلاثه ايام غياب الموت الاسطوره
البرازيلي ولاعب كره القدم المخضرم بيليه
عن عمر ناهز 82 عاما ونقل ناش بطل العالم
لثلاث مرات لملعب نادي سانتوس في البرازيل
لتقام مراسم وداعه اما الجنازه فرح تكون
بكره واجتمع الاف المشجعين في ساحه الملعب
لاستقبال موكب بطل كره القدم فيليه ولا
القاء نظره الوداع الاخيره عليه
جايزكا
عموما هذا اقل ما يمكن انه ينعمل بحق هيك
انسان عمل تاريخ لنفسه ولبده ولا كره
القدم عالميا صحيفه داسن البريطانيه قالت
انه الراحل اختار مقبره خارجه عن المقلوب
لحتى يدفن فيها وما راح تكون تحت الارض بل
تحديدا في الطابق التاسع من مبنى فخم يطل
على ملعب سانتوس المكان اللي تالق فيه
وحظيه باكبر النجاحات في عالم كره القدم
الصحيفه البريطانيه كشفت انه بيليه امضاء
كثير من الوقت لاختيار مكانه الاخير وانه
اختار انه يدفن في الطابق التاسع من
المقبره العموديه تكريما لوالده دوندينو
اللي كان لاعب لكره القدم كذلك واعتاد انه
يرتدي القميص رقم تسعه دائما كثير تفاصيل
محيطه بمراسم الدفن ما زالت سريه مشاهدينا
لكن الصحيفه البريطانيه قالت انه المعلوم
حتى الان انه تابوت سيكون ذهبيا وستكون
على جوانب العديد من المنحوتات ما فيهوش
لصور بلاي الايقونه
[موسيقى]